well the u.s. is one of only four
countries in the world with the drinking
age as high as 21 the other three are
Indonesia Mongolia and Palau
I would encourage someone to to refrain
from alcohol use until they turn 21
there are lots of things that people can
do that don't involve alcohol 18 19 20
year-olds are going to drink there's
just no getting around we're here in
Menomonie Wisconsin at UW Stout to get a
first-hand look at the war on underage
drinking Menomonie Wisconsin is a little
town on a lake about an hour east of the
Twin Cities on i-94 people here enjoy
hunting fishing eating deep-fried cheese
curds and drinking in fact the nice
folks here in Wisconsin are more likely
to binge drink than people anywhere else
in the country Menominee's population of
15,000 swells to 24,000 during the
school year and students who choose to
attend stout to know exactly what
they're getting into
a party school UW Stout has always been
known as a place where people like to go
out and have a good time at in the late
1970s Ron Fox attended stout and worked
as a bartender at the flame the bar he
now owns at that time the drinking age
again was 18 we had people in here all
the time Tuesday through Saturday night
Stout is still clinging to its party
school identity but it hasn't been easy
Wisconsin raised its drinking age to 21
back in 1986
well obviously the bar scene is taking a
big hit financially so where are all the
underage students what the strict
enforcement has done is it has chased
the people into drinking behind closed
doors John McArdle is a former
Chancellor of Middlebury College in
Vermont and the president of an
organization called choose
responsibility a choose responsibility
was founded in December of 2006 and our
purpose is principally to engage the
public in informed and dispassionate
discussion about the effects of the 21
year old drinking age Marybeth Griffin
is the interim executive director of the
Orange County Chapter of Mothers Against
Drunk Driving the mission Mothers
Against Drunk Driving is to stop drunk
driving support victims of this violent
crime and prevent underage drinking for
better or worse Mothers Against Drunk
Driving recommended to a special
Presidential Commission which in turn
recommended to an otherwise strict
states rights president that the most
effective way to address the problem of
drunken driving was to raise the
drinking age from 18 to 21 the law says
that the states may continue to set the
age wherever they choose but if they
said it lower than 21 they forfeit 10%
of their highway funds Wisconsin and
several other states held out for a
while but by 1988 all 50 states had
raised the drinking age to 21 and more
than 20 years later Menominee police are
still working hard to enforce the
drinking age that is one of their top
priorities is to combat 18 19 20
year-old kids there
try to catch them with a beer in their
hand can I get off work around midnight
man died during things like homecoming
and that type of thing they actually get
into almost a Gestapo type mode you know
at the local cops in cooperation with
Arbor Place a state-funded alcohol and
drug treatment center routinely
organized compliance checks and sting
operations resulting in fines for
underage drinkers and bar owners some of
those busted for underage drinking are
persuaded to help the cops catch other
underage drinkers people who get
underaged tickets will end up making a
deal with the DA and the police
department to have these tickets
disappear and they will come in and we
asked the Menominee cops to discuss the
challenge of enforcing the drinking age
but they wouldn't talk to us and Arbor
place wouldn't return our calls so we
contacted Charles Sorenson who has
served as UW stouts chancellor for more
than 20 years chancellor Sorenson is
very very against underage drinking
chancellor Sorenson wouldn't talk to us
either Arbor place in the police
department and City Council and people
like that are not gonna want to talk to
you because for them underage drinking
has become a cash cow the situation at
stout is hardly unique but frustrated
Chancellor's at other universities
around the country believe it's time for
change the amethyst initiative is a
statement signed now by a hundred and
thirty five presidents and chancellors
of college and universities across the
country the situation on college
campuses right now is that to observe
the law requires presidents to say
prohibition just say no but we also see
how that's playing out and that
frustration led these presidents to sign
the amethyst initiative which suggests
that the 10 percent highway fund
incentive is a barrier to debate so what
are the main arguments in the National
debates surrounding the drinking age if
if on the one hand you're being told
that you possess the maturity and the
judgment and the sufficiently developed
brain to serve on a jury
to sign allah to sign a contract to take
out a loan it's very hard then to ask
well and then oh and why can't i buy a
beer well because you lack maturity
judgment and brain development for
people to be considered 18 at an adult
at 18 it really is a rights and
responsibility issue people starting to
drink at 21 is a public health and
safety issue there are there's been
research that's been done on adolescent
brains and we understand now what the
introduction of alcohol can do to a
young person's brain if introduced too
early fact of the matter is that one of
the principal researchers in that area
is a member of the board of choose
responsibility and he's the first to
issue a cautionary reminder that this
research is in its very early stages it
is based solely on laboratory animals
and it has concluded that the brain of
an adolescent rat has not fully matured
until approximately the human age of 25
drinking and driving crashes of teen
teenagers in between 15 and 20 years old
have significantly been reduced drunken
driving fatalities have gone down in
every age group over the last 25 years
that suggests it's something other than
the drinking age may also be responsible
safer automobile seatbelts airbags of
greater enforcement zero-tolerance one
thing everyone involved in the debate
can agree upon is that clandestine
drinking puts too many young people at
risk and we are now in a situation where
by far the greater loss of life of those
under age 21 to alcohol is occurring off
the highways illegal drinkers I think
are more likely to binge because they
find themselves in environments where
normal adult behavior is less likely to
occur
[Music]
there you're gonna be restricted how
much you can drink on how much to do
where is the house we're not gonna get
kicked out or be cut off
now her drink somebody's gonna think
that's sweet when you have to hide
something that's when you get your
problems that mean that's when you get
your troubles that's when you get your
friend we drank too much who really
needs to go to the hospital but they're
underage and so you you don't want to do
anything about it
despite concerted efforts to enforce the
drinking age in college towns like
Menominee 18 to 20 year olds continue to
drink alcohol where do we go from here
so some of the things that I think that
we can continue to do in order to help
minimize the problem help make our teens
safer help get them to their 21st
birthday is continued education
continued enforcement of underage
drinking laws and closing some of the
loopholes in our existing underage
drinking laws here's a good analogy
think think about driving what if on the
day a young person reached legal driving
age whatever that age is we toss the
keys to the car to that person and said
you're the keys
there's the vehicle good luck in
figuring out how to operate this 2,000
pound machine capable of going 90 miles
an hour maybe your friends can help you
maybe you can go off into some dark
secluded place and master its operation
I would love as your parent to be able
to help you do this but unfortunately if
I did you and I would both be arrested
and our state would forfeit 10% of its
highway funds so mmm good luck go figure
it out well that is precisely silly as
that sounds that is precisely the
attitude we take towards alcohol
the old argument goes if they're old
enough to die for their country then why
not let him go out to have a couple of
beers so what do you think is it time
that we took a fresh look at the
drinking age for reason TV
I'm Paul fine
[Music]